it has been one month since the end of
the world 30 long days since stella had
watched her husband dissolve in front of
her one minute mowing the lawn like it
was any other lazy afternoon and the
next collapsing into a useless pile of
flesh and jelly the end didn't come like
she always thought it would with
hellfire raining down and pale riders
galloping across the land on horseback
it began in the kitchen with her humming
a song to herself mixing up a pitcher of
lemonade before she rejoined her family
in the sunshine then they were gone lost
forever when the sun
turned wrong she didn't even have time
to grieve them properly before the
threat turned on her as the creatures
that had once been her husband her son
and her daughter swarmed the door
slamming their new bodies against the
wood with wet slaps calling out to her
in warped voices begging her to step
back outside she covered her ears and
wept for hours until she had no tears
left to cry it didn't take long for
stella to figure out that whatever had
happened to her family it was happening
all over the world the small town she
had known and loved had transformed into
a hellscape a maze of monsters and
deadly light she retreated underground
two old mine shafts and tunnels left
abandoned decades ago when the local
cold trade had dried up there she
quickly discovered that she wasn't the
only one with that idea there were
others survivors who had managed to make
their way down into the dark away from
the horrors above there weren't many and
she could never get too attached to the
ones she did meet in case they too were
lost to the sun but as the days were on
in the tunnels she found herself forming
a small group of stragglers not quite a
family but something that could be one
day and definitely much better than
going it alone there was stella of
course using her background as an
elementary school teacher to keep
everyone on track and working together
then there was brian a former volunteer
firefighter whose training and skills
with an axe came in handy more than once
there was trina a teenage girl who had
been babysitting when everything went to
hell who had a knack for evading the
flesh monsters and making supply runs
and then there was doris former military
nurse and current de facto team medic
sharp and capable in spite of being in
her late 70s they were brave people
brilliant and refused to give up others
came and went spare survivors they
picked up as they navigated their way
raiding the ruins of grocery stores and
hospitals but they always wound up
leaving again or worse something would
go wrong and the sunlight would claim
another victim but the four of them
stayed together stronger with their
combined skills willpower and ability to
sleep in shifts and keep an eye out for
trouble after some time in the tunnels
the group had come across a massive
abandoned facility none of them could
determine where it came from or what
organization might have run it but it
appeared to have been some kind of
research lab it was isolated cut off
from outside influences better than any
of their previous hideouts had been
whoever had once worked here had cleared
out or been taken out in a hurry but in
their place they had left behind rations
medical equipment emergency generators
and clean drinking water there were
enough supplies to keep the group going
for months if they rationed carefully
and so they settled in the abandoned
research facility whatever it once was
became their makeshift home this
unexpected sanctuary was cut off from
the rest of the world clinical cold
lonely but a safe place for them to rest
their heads now it had been a month
since this all began stella shook her
head at this realization the passage of
time feeling almost meaningless at this
point what did a month even mean anymore
what was a day when she couldn't even
see the sun rise and set as she sat
there warming herself by the side of a
foraged space heater she thought about
missing the stars the moon the promise
of the cosmos a time when the vast open
sky was an invitation to dream instead
of something to hide from that time was
gone now there was nothing to do but
mourn it and carry on if not for her
than for the others they had all found
ways to keep busy in this new place
trina took to exploring the empty halls
the laboratories filled with strange
equipment the small rooms that looked
like prison cells or police
interrogation rooms she had cooked up
some theory about it being a government
facility like something out of an old
episode of the x-files brian had found
an on-site library filled with history
books and scientific texts there was
enough to read and there he said that by
the time he was finished he would have
the equivalent of several doctorate
degrees doris had taken initial stock of
all the medical supplies available at
the site gauze disinfectant vials upon
vials of medications she had never heard
of and had categorized them all neatly
now she spent her hours mostly sitting
with stella telling her stories about
whatever she felt like her time overseas
her late husband their children
decades-old neighborhood gossip it felt
good to talk no matter what it was about
it felt human they all had their ways of
keeping their grip on their own humanity
it had almost gotten boring holed up in
the facility without the constant threat
of danger pressing in from all sides
boring but peaceful stella could feel
herself starting to nod off her eyelids
sagging her dinner of canned beans
sitting heavy in her stomach next to her
doris had already begun to softly snore
soon sleep would come for her too and
bring with it dreams memory of the life
that was gone forever the world as she
had once known it the dreams were tough
but waking up from them was even tougher
still she had to rest she could only
fight it for so long she could almost
hear her husband's voice when hey stella
you might want to see this brian was
there suddenly his words breaking
through the haze in her mind his tone
was severe and she knew that sleep would
have to wait she followed him down the
hall for a while before he stopped and
turned her attention to a section of a
damaged wall it was rusted and corroded
black and gray with massive cracks in
the solid material it looked like it had
been slowly disintegrated over time by
an incredibly strong acid it was
off-putting to look at giving off the
distinct sense that something bad had
happened but a lot of bad things had
happened in the past month i don't
really understand what i'm looking at
stella said and brian grabbed her by the
shoulders commanding her attention this
wasn't here yesterday hell it wasn't
here a few hours ago he gestured to the
damage it just happened and whatever is
responsible is probably still here a
chill ran down stella's spine it seemed
impossible for this kind of structural
damage to happen over the course of a
few hours she could see twisted steel
rebar drips of melted metal that had
trickled onto the floor as she leaned in
for a closer look she gagged there was
an overpowering stench of rot and decay
it didn't take long for her to spot the
source a thick black mucus covering the
hole in the wall
slick and slimy and giving off the
putrid smell it wasn't like the material
that had made up the flesh creatures
outside it was something else entirely
something she had never seen before she
reached out a hand to touch it but
quickly caught herself whatever this
stuff was it was bad news if it could do
that to a solid wall she didn't even
want to think about what it could do to
flash and bone what do we do she asked
inspect the area make sure it's safe see
if it's some kind of toxic waste leak or
he didn't finish the thought he didn't
have to they needed to find out if this
damage came from something living
something that could be hiding in the
building with them and waiting for the
chance to strike when they returned to
the main room doris was awake and trina
was there waiting for them they agreed
to split into pairs and search the
facility looking for any additional
damage strange black fluid or signs of
foul play of any kind trina and brian
went one way while doris and stella went
the other each person armed with a
flashlight and a weapon of some kind an
axe a bat a knife stella had found a
loaded pistol when they first arrived
one that she hoped she would never have
to use now she carried it with her just
in case stella and doris walked together
for an hour keeping an eye out for
anything suspicious they didn't find
anything notable really there were some
bits of rust they hadn't seen before an
occasional black puddle pooling on the
floor but nothing like the scene brian
had found as they walked in silence
stella found herself beginning to relax
maybe the worst was over maybe a pipe
had broken somewhere and broken down a
bit of the wall but nothing else would
really come of it then from the other
side of the building there came a
high-pitched scream she knew that voice
immediately trina screaming bloody
murder and brian bellowing something she
grabbed doris by the arm and the two ran
in the direction of the sound as they
got closer they could hear other sounds
in addition to trina and brian's yells
loud cracking like something solid
coming apart bits of rubble falling to
the ground and the wet dripping sound of
something thick hitting the floor as the
two rounded the corner to see what was
happening to help their friends stella
froze in shock she had seen some
harrowing things since that fateful
sunny day she almost thought she had
become desensitized to horror that there
was nothing left in the world that could
face her but this moment proved her
wrong there was so much to take in and
so little time brian was swinging his
axe wildly at the floor chopping at it
helplessly in an attempt to break it
apart it quickly became obvious why
trina was sinking into the floor not
through a hole into the basement below
but into the floor itself it rippled and
melted around her changing from a solid
surface to a thick pool of black sludge
she flailed and struggled grasping at
the ground around her at brian's arm
anything to yank herself free but she
wouldn't budge she continued to sink no
she wasn't just sinking she was being
pulled stella felt her legs begin to
work again and she rushed to trina's
side grabbing hold of her arms with all
the strength she had all the while trina
screamed in a mix of desperation terror
and pain brian continued his assault on
the ground as if he could cut her free
from the floor and doris moved to help
stella she grabbed a hold of trina's
waist but stopped suddenly there at the
place where her body vanished into the
floor trina was beginning to fall apart
whatever had turned the floor into a
portal whatever had rotted away at the
walls it was taking its toll on her body
too the flesh falling away from the bone
the muscles liquefying and everything
becoming corrupted by that same black
mucus if they pulled any harder trina
would be ripped in two her chest arms
and head on the surface while her legs
stomach and most of her vital organs
were lost there was no way to save her
stella saw it when doris did and the two
shared a long sad look trina was here
with them still struggling for her life
but she was already gone as if it felt
their hopelessness the force pulling on
trina from below then gave a horrifying
yank they were praying to not have to
witness and she was swallowed up by the
ground all that remained was a sticky
black smear a large crack in the floor
and three survivors where there had just
been four none of the remaining three
slept a wink that night brian paced back
and forth
holding his axe doris went over their
supplies again looking for anything that
could be used to treat the effects of
the corrosive black fluid and stella ran
over their potential options again and
again they could stay and hope that the
thing that took trina never came back or
they could leave and face the
possibility of succumbing to the sun or
the influence of the creatures that once
were people she recalled dimly an old
adage the devil you know beats the devil
you don't maybe that was true
maybe it would be better to take their
chances with the outside rather than
stay and be hunted but she thought of
her husband and children again watching
them melt onto the grass and she
shuddered there were no good options
here but she couldn't risk going out
like that they would stay whatever had
taken trina there were three of them and
only one of it besides maybe it had
already gotten what it wanted and now it
would move on she didn't know it when
she fell asleep only that when she
eventually woke up she was alone brian
and doris were nowhere to be found she
called out their names as her heart
leaped into her throat for a moment she
feared the very worst but then brian
answered her he had been patrolling
looking for signs of trouble but he was
fine she asked if doris was with him and
he went pale he told stella that doris
had gone to an on-site bathroom to get
cleaned up hours ago before he left she
should have been back by then without
another thought they took off towards
the bathroom and saw their worst fear
realized the door to the room was gone
rotted away and doris was gone with it
she had been taken before she even had
the chance to scream they stood there
taking in the reality of what had
happened with silent shock then a sound
from behind caused them to turn around
it was a raspy hollowed-out sound like
air forced from a dying man's lungs a
dry
empty evil chuckle from an inhuman
throat there they saw the creature that
had stolen their friends from a distance
stella could have confused it for a man
a very old very sick man but still human
as it shuffled closer however that
illusion was shattered its eyes were
black voids its skin gray and putrefied
its mouth a gaping toothless maw of
shriveled black gums and it was laughing
at them like it was enjoying itself
there was the smell again that
overpowering reek of all things foul
stella drew her pistol and fired several
shots she didn't have the best aim
especially not when their hands were
shaking with fear but one of the bullets
found its target and hit the creature in
the cheek it hissed not in pain but a
perverse amusement as the lead tore a
hole through its flesh like wet paper
globs of black blood spattered
everywhere spreading the rot wherever
they landed to her side she heard brian
cry out in pain when she turned he was
clutching his right eye some of the
liquid had hit him there and it was
already taking effect stella's stomach
turned as she saw something white slide
down the side of brian's face his eye
melting out of its socket the skin
around it followed suit softening like
putty and dribbling away from the bloody
muscle underneath brine collapsed to the
floor as the creature continued to
advance on them laughing louder and
louder it knew that bullets couldn't
kill it knew that there was nowhere to
run stella grabbed a hold of brian's
arms prepared to carry her fallen friend
to safety but he stopped her i'm done
for he said quietly if you try to carry
me
you are too she shook her head unwilling
to leave him behind and he touched her
cheek forcing a smile on his decaying
face i
i didn't think i'd make it this far i i
wouldn't have without you so run save
yourself she could hear the resignation
in his voice and knew that he would not
let her save him i'll hold him off as
long as i can brian promised and with
tears in her eyes stella turned and ran
as fast as she could as her feet pounded
the ground blood rushing in her ears she
could hear brian screaming and cursing
at the creature until his voice quickly
faded into a wet gurgle and then
silence stella sat in the center of the
room that she and the others had once
shared clutching her scavenged pistol in
her hands every creak every air and
sound made her jump it could be anywhere
come from anywhere she had escaped from
so much already survived more than
anyone was ever meant to had lost her
love her friends her home she wouldn't
lose herself too she held her breath as
she heard it clear in the darkness drip
drip grip her grip on the weapon
tightened and she readied herself if she
had to go down she might as well go down
swinging the old man whether he was a
man a monster or death itself wouldn't
be taking her anywhere not without a
fight now go check out
scp-106 the old man tale until death and
scp-001 when daybreaks for more on the
old man and what happens to the world
when the sun turns against humanity